the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video in this video
i will be discussing one of the new
official announcements recently released
by hbo
now as i'm sure most of you know by now
hbo has been releasing a lot of new
information this week regarding their
new game of thrones successor show house
of the dragon
only a few days ago they released nearly
a dozen new photos that showcase some of
their main actors from the upcoming show
as always it was very exciting to see
some new high def images of these
amazing characters however with that
being said we already had a good idea
about who these characters are and which
actors and actresses will be playing
them not only have we seen some of the
actors on set in some of the leaked
photos but hbo made an official
announcement about them several months
ago as well
what we haven't known is what actors and
actresses will fill out some of the
other secondary characters
well hbo has finally officially
announced which actors will be filling
their shoes on the official hbo website
they have now listed who these actors
are and which characters they will be
let's have a look now for those of you
who aren't very familiar with some of
these characters i will go over some of
their background information
let's start this off by going over one
of the heavy hitters and that is none
other than aegon targaryen the firstborn
son of king viserys targaryen and his
wife alison hightower the actor they
have found for this character is a man
that goes by the name of tom glenn
carney who definitely looks like a great
aegon if you ask me now as you can see
this aegon is the son of king viserys
and his wife alison hightower he will be
the one who sits on the iron throne
immediately after his father viserys
targaryen dies
this is also who rhaenyra targaryen will
be fighting for the iron throne now
what's interesting about aegon is he
initially doesn't want the iron throne
for himself
after king viserys dies aegon thinks the
iron throne should go to his half-sister
rhaenyra since he knows that their
father named her as his successor
now the reason why he eventually decides
to take it for himself is because alison
and her father serato hightower began
telling him that rhaenyra will remove
their heads after aegon does claim the
iron throne for himself it's not long
before he starts to fully embrace it in
fact he will be ready to fight rhaenyra
to the death in order to keep it we will
eventually see aegon and his dragon
inflict some vicious and savage attacks
on rhaenyra and her allies
rhaenys gleefully began to incinerate
sir kristen's army
but aegon had set a trap and rhaenys had
flown right into it as rhaenys and
melees blanketed sir christian's troops
and dragonflame two other dragons rose
into the sky eamonn on vegar and king
aegon himself on the gleaming sun fire
make sure you buckle your seatbelts
because this character will have us in
for one hell of a ride and so will his
brother aim on one eye targaryen hbo has
also officially announced what actor
will fill the role of this character
ewen mitchell will be our aemon
targaryen the second born son of king
viserys targaryen and alison hightower
he will also be willing to fight to the
death in order for his brother aegon to
stay seated on the iron throne not only
that but he will also be responsible for
some of the most brutal dragon attacks
we will see in this show among one eye
will be riding the dragon known as vegar
who will not only be the largest dragon
in the show but it's also said that
veigar had grown nearly as big as
balerion the black dread during these
events i for one cannot wait to see this
dragon get brought to life on the screen
during the dance of the dragons
the sun was close to setting when as one
the two dragons leapt into the sky damon
took her axis up swiftly until they
disappeared into a bank of clouds vegard
older and slower ascended more gradually
up and up vega sword searching for
karazzis
let's move on to the next casting
announcement now as you should all know
by now rhaenyra targaryen is king
viserys targaryen's firstborn daughter
his second born daughter who he has with
his new wife alicent is a character
known as helena targaryen
the actress who landed this role is fia
sabin
now not only is helena targaryen aegon's
sister but she will be his wife as well
i mean this is house targaryen after all
so this is nothing new with them as you
can see hbo has nearly found all of the
actors and actresses they will need for
king viserys and allison hightower's
children the only one who is missing as
of right now is their youngest son daron
targaryen i would actually not be
shocked if they left him out of the show
now let's have a look at who hbo has
found for some of daemon targaryen's
children actresses bethany antonia and
phoebe campbell will be our older bayla
and reina targaryen they are the
daughters of daemon targaryen and his
first wife lady laina velaryon now for
those of you who don't know lady laina
velaryon is the daughter of lord corliss
velaryon and his wife rhaenys targaryen
lady elena is actually daemon's second
wife and we will most likely see her die
very early on in the first season
now their daughters bayla and reina do
have dragons of their own but i'm not
expecting to see them in much of the
action during the dance of the dragons
however with that being said hbo and
their writers very well could have them
do whatever they want now let's have a
look at rhaenyra targaryen's eldest son
jacary's velaryon hbo has now announced
that actor harry kaulit will be rjcarys
who also goes by the name of jace he is
the firstborn son of rhaenyra targaryen
and her first husband sir lanor velaryon
son of lord corliss velaryon
now although sir lanor is listed as the
father of rhaenyra's son jacarys there
are rumors that he was actually fathered
by another man you see rhaenyra
targaryen was sleeping around with
several other men during these events
not only that but we should see that her
husband sir laynor valerion favors men
more than he does women now as of right
now hbo hasn't made any other official
announcements regarding rhaenyra's other
sons
we'll have to wait and see if they find
actors for these characters or if they
will even include them at all in the
show there are some other actors hbo has
listed on their website but i already
went over them in another one of my
videos therefore i won't do that again
here that way i can keep the video short
and sweet i wanted to give you a brief
introduction of some of the children of
our main characters we will be seeing a
lot of them in the first season of house
of the dragon
now make sure you remember their faces
because you will either grow to love or
hate them soon enough
make sure you subscribe so you can stay
updated on all of the new information
about game of thrones house of the
dragon and a song of ice and fire there
are a lot of new videos heading your way
have a great day everyone i will see you
again very soon
bye
[Music]
so
you